et puis toute cette semaine nous avons
décidé de vous emmener sur les traces de
Léonard de Vinc et oui à l'occasion de
la sortie du film Léo qui retrace les
années de tourangel du génie chaque soir
nous vous ferons découvrir quelques
aspects de sa vie notamment sa vie
entourain bien sûr et ce soir on va
parler de la plus fameuse œuvre sans
doute de Léonard de Vincy la Joconde
évidemment Aurélien vous le saviez euh
saviez-vous par ailleurs que vous
pouviez l'observer à tour non et voilà
et même en plusieurs et oui même en
plusieurs exemplaires vous allez le voir
puisque Clémence Dosque vous emmène à la
découverte des jumelles tourangel du
sourire le plus célèbre du
monde au côté de ces deux vierges à
l'enfant elle rafle toutes les attention
cette copie du célèbre tableau de
Léonard devincy est issue d'une saisie
révolutionnaire au château de
richelieu d'un point de vue technique
l'œuvre est très différente de celle de
Léonard de Vinc puisque vous voyez
qu'elle est c'est une presque une image
euh de de Mona Lisa mais qui n'a qui n'a
pas la technique du sfumato euh tel que
la pratiquait Léonard de Vincy vous
voyez que c'est une œuvre qui est
beaucoup plus plate euh qui n'a pas
cette profondeur et cette douceur euh
que l'on peut trouver dans dans
l'original deux copies sont exposées au
Musée des beauards de tour et réalisé
par des artistes anonymes leur présence
surprennent et interpellent les
visiteurs peu habitué à voir une
Monalisa d'ussi près
donc elle a tout de suite eu une très
forte renommée puisque c'est devenu une
œuvre rentrée dans la collection royale
on sait que Léonard de vincite nait
beaucoup donc il l'a même transporté en
France enfin voilà donc ça a été une
œuvre très importante mais finalement il
faut attendre le 19e siècle même la fin
du 19e siècle pour qu'elle prenne un
statut d'icône finalement c'est
quasiment lorsqu'elle est volée au
Louvre en 1911 et qu'elle est retrouvver
2 ans plus tard qu'elle devient enfin
qu'elle prend une célébrité
internationale avant finalement elle
était connue mais seulement d'un d'un
milieu de spécialiste près de 130 copies
de la Joconde ont été recensées dans le
monde elles sont réparties entre
collection particulière et Musée ouvrez
l'œil au détour d'un couloir vous
pourriez
[Musique]
l'apercevoir